[Música]
bienvenidos a la crónica ambiental de
france 24 yo soy maría jara calle
bienvenidos se cumplen 50 años de la
primera conferencia mundial sobre el
medio ambiente que la onu organizó en la
ciudad sueca de estocolmo en 1972 y han
sido cinco décadas de diplomacia y
multilateralismo para intentar enfrentar
la destrucción ambiental en este tiempo
por ejemplo se han pactado compromisos
relevantes como los objetivos de
desarrollo sostenible el acuerdo de
parís sobre el cambio climático o el
marco mundial de la biodiversidad post
2020 pero los esfuerzos no han sido
suficientes para frenar las tres crisis
que afronta el planeta el cambio
climático la pérdida de biodiversidad y
la contaminación por eso líderes
mundiales se reunieron del 2 al 3 de
junio en estocolmo más 50 en la capital
sueca no sólo hablaron de los 50 años de
la lucha ambiental sino también de luque
el propósito de esta reunión es que nos
vayamos a casa desde aquí y hagamos
mucho más
y que lo hagamos mucho más rápido esto
no es para hacer nuevas promesas es para
cumplir las promesas que ya hemos hecho
el email
ya hablamos ahora es el momento de
recorrer el camino
uno de los aprendizajes de este tiempo
es que no solo los gobiernos están
llamados a actuar siguiendo el ejemplo
de países como francia o reino unido
españa formó en 2021 una asamblea
ciudadana por el clima está integrada
por 100 personas elegidas en un sorteo
aleatorio durante 8 meses han debatido
las medidas necesarias para frenar la
crisis climática el resultado es que el
6 de junio el grupo le entregó sus
conclusiones al presidente del gobierno
español pedro sánchez desde madrid
nuestra corresponsal marina colorado nos
cuenta los resultados
172 recomendaciones que buscan acelerar
las acciones climáticas para conseguir
una españa más segura y justa ante el
cambio climático la primera asamblea
ciudadana por el clima del país que
llegó con dos años de retraso pide que
se llegue a un pacto de estado contra el
cambio climático para que las acciones
no dependan de quien esté en el gobierno
y así las decisiones climáticas sean
duraderas fueron asesorados por equipos
de especialistas y las propuestas se han
agrupado en cinco áreas consumo
alimentación y usos del suelo comunidad
salud y cuidados trabajo y ecosistemas
algunas de las recomendaciones son
regular la publicidad de mensajes que
invitan al consumo descontrolado de
nuestra sociedad que también el cambio
climático sea una asignatura obligatoria
en la educación primaria y secundaria
y por ejemplo en el transporte el sector
que más contribuye al cambio climático
en españa y en el mundo
proponen priorizar el tren frente al
avión en viajes nacionales como por
ejemplo de menos de 350 kilómetros
además de promover el teletrabajo y las
semanas laborales de cuatro días para
así reducir los desplazamientos en un
país en el que el 75 del territorio está
en riesgo de desertificación la asamblea
ciudadana por el clima exige la
reutilización de aguas y la colección de
agua lluvia en edificios de todo tipo
esta semana el gobierno aprobó una de
las recomendaciones incluidas en el
texto una ley contra las pérdidas y el
desperdicio alimentario que de ser
ratificada por el congreso y el senado
entraría en vigor el 2 de enero del año
que viene y haría que españa se
convierta en el tercer país europeo en
tener una legislación al respecto
después de francia o italia como ven
recomendaciones con bastante sentido
común y de las que no se han estado
hablando los científicos desde hace
décadas que esperemos el gobierno de
españa' escuché sólo el tiempo dirá si
estas ideas ciudadanas impulsan cambios
y acciones para que españa alcance el
objetivo de cero emisiones en 2050 al
que se comprometió como contexto menos
de un año después de las iniciativas
ciudadanas en francia allí se
implementaron 75 de las 149 propuestas y
la acción ambiental importa pues las
consecuencias de la crisis climática son
evidentes en honduras por ejemplo las
recurrentes sequías son cada vez más
fuertes y están creando una crisis
alimentaria más de 130 municipios del
sur hondureño fueron declarados en
emergencia porque el tiempo seco extremo
está afectando cosechas de maíz y frijol
la historia la tiene nuestra
corresponsal kenia torres
los alimentos para la familia de arturo
colindres no están garantizados este año
la zona donde se ubica la parcela para
sembrar los frijoles que son el sustento
de su hogar ha sido declarada en
emergencia por sequía estamos bien
preocupados en la forma de qué
la lluvia son son ruina bye pero al
mismo tiempo las necesidades de nosotros
es sembrar el maíz para producir pero
estamos preocupados porque están en una
de las peores sequías que hemos tenido
en estos municipios de choluteca 200.000
familias de 132 municipios están
ubicadas en ese corredor seco en la zona
sur de honduras los suelos áridos ya
afectaron a la primera cosecha del año
de maíz y de frijoles los dos alimentos
más consumidos en el país
no se queda el suelo todo se perdió el
programa mundial de alimentos y el
gobierno de xiomara castró han diseñado
un plan de ayuda para evitar una
hambruna en las zonas afectadas en
primer lugar hay una acción conjunta
entre la secretaría desarrollo solidario
y también la secretaria de cultura y
ganadería en donde van a desarrollar
proyectos específicos de las comunidades
más pobres de la zona
en segundo lugar van a dar un bono
tecnológico y se van a comenzar a
instalar sistemas de riego entidades
internacionales como la fao y
organizaciones de ayuda humanitaria
señalan que más del 50 por ciento de la
población del corredor seco honduras
sufre de una severa crisis alimentaria y
muy pronto estarán al límite de la
pobreza extrema
antes de terminar esta emisión un
anuncio france24 con nuestra crónica
ambiental está en la primera cumbre
amazónica de comunicación y periodismo
contra el cambio climático organizada
por fundamedios en puyo ecuador
y nosotros nos vemos en otra ocasión
[Música]